[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente y este es nuestro
recorrido de hoy
empezamos en perú porque crecen las
voces pidiendo que el presidente pedro
castillo renuncie a poco más de seis
meses de su llegada al poder el
mandatario ha cambiado su gabinete
cuatro veces en la última semana lo hizo
en dos oportunidades
y conductores de camión bloquean el
puente internacional más concurrido de
américa del norte el andador que conecta
a eeuu y canadá son las manifestaciones
de movimientos antivacunas que nacieron
en territorio canadiense donde
paradójicamente el 80% de la población
ya está vacunada y es que movimientos de
ultraderecha en eeuu estarían buscando
beneficios de estas protestas que en año
electoral son una oportunidad al tiempo
que encuestas revelan que los
estadounidenses están perdiendo la
confianza en la democracia como nos lo
cuenta nuestro corresponsal en
washington
pero vamos de inmediato a perú para
revisar la cifra de la semana
4 en 6 les explico el presidente pedro
castillo cambio por cuarta vez en sus
apenas seis meses de mandato a su primer
ministro el cambio lo hizo por apaciguar
las críticas del congreso que amenazaba
con invocar la cuestión de confianza
este es el mecanismo de la constitución
para remover a un mandatario del cargo
pues sobre el anterior primer ministro
héctor valer pese a una denuncia de
violencia intrafamiliar
un pulso de poder que alimenta la crisis
perpetua peruana ya que crecen las voces
de opositores para que renuncie afirman
que es incapaz de gobernar y es evidente
que a medio año de llegar al poder no ha
podido conformar su gabinete veamos más
en el informe que preparamos para
ustedes en la redacción de aquí américa
a los 70 días de asumir el cargo llegó
la primera crisis las críticas al
entonces primer ministro guido bellido
empezaron a atraer el fantasma de la
destitución
polémico por simpatizar con el grupo
terrorista sendero luminoso así como por
decir que en cuba no hay una dictadura
entre otros pensamientos controversiales
el presidente pedro castillo cambió por
primera vez al gabinete en octubre y dio
un aparente giro hacia el centro lo que
se pensaba iba a calmar a los críticos
que en campaña lo señalaron de querer
llevar el modelo chavista a perú
invoco a los sectores políticos
económicos y sociales a la más amplia
unidad para lograr juntos los objetivos
comunes que tenemos como nación pero no
fue así
castilho nombró a mirtha vásquez como
presidenta del consejo de ministros y
cambio otros seis altos cargos sí juro
pero el nombramiento de vázquez creó una
ruptura en el partido oficialista
mientras que a los legisladores de
derecha les disgusta porque es cercana
al reclamo indígena de la defensa de las
tierras de compañías mineras
a finales de enero llegó la renuncia de
la primera ministra tras la dimisión del
ministro del interior para reemplazar la
castillo nombró a héctor valer y acto
seguido se conoce una denuncia de
violencia familiar que lo llevó a
permanecer menos de una semana en el
cargo aníbal torres fue nombrado en
reemplazo como jefe de gabinete el
abogado que lo defendió de las
acusaciones de fraude de keiko fujimori
del gabinete con el que castillo llegó a
finales de julio sólo quedan cuatro
ministros en la última reforma removió
al ministro de salud a hernando ceballos
el que paradójicamente tenía el mayor
índice de aprobación según las encuestas
debido a la vacunación contra el joven
19 el problema de este gabinete no es
tanto el nombramiento de aníbal torres
sino a quien se desee pudo haber
nombrado y no se nombró y se sacó del
gabinete y me refiero al ministro de
salud
el señor zevallos que a
y he sido el único éxito indiscutible
que ha tenido este gobierno hasta este
momento que es la vacunación
más de 20 millones de peruanos tienen 2
vacunas y por lo tanto esta protección
contra una muerte por este por este
virus y las críticas del congreso esta
vez llegaron por la cercanía de torres
con la familia del ex presidente ollanta
humala y por cuenta de la dificultad que
ha tenido para formar su gabinete y
empezar a gobernar y con el poderoso
congreso peruano que ha hecho que haya
seis presidentes en cinco años gracias a
la cláusula de la constitución que le
permite retirarlo del cargo castillo
podría ser sólo uno más en la lista
el denominado convoy de la libertad
sacudió a canadá esta semana los
conductores de camión decidieron
bloquear la frontera más concurrida de
américa del norte el puente ambassador
que une a la ciudad canadiense de
windsor en ontario con la estadounidense
de detroit en michigan por allí pasa
generalmente un cuarto de todo el
comercio entre ambos países tanto los
legisladores en canadá como en la casa
blanca han expresado su preocupación por
el impacto económico de las protestas
contra la obligatoriedad de las vacunas
y otras restricciones contra el kobe 19
que han sido aprovechados por grupos de
extrema derecha veamos más en el informe
de nuestros corresponsales
es suficiente es suficiente estamos aquí
para terminar con la obligatoriedad
llegaron a ottawa el 28 de enero primero
en rechazo a las vacunas obligatorias
exigidas a los camioneros doce días
después mil vehículos se tomaron la
capital y afirmaron que no se iban a
mover hasta que todas las restricciones
contra el kobe 19 fueran levantadas
estamos trabajando con las autoridades
ahora hemos hecho bastantes la vacuna
obligatoria en algunas provincias fue
levantada y los conservadores están
buscando un nuevo líder si todos
hubieran puesto su atención en el
gobierno obligándolos a sentarse y
hablar con nosotros se habrían enfocado
en eso en vez de mandar policía pesada
ha sido solo paz unidad y amor aquí no
hay necesidad de estado de emergencia
era innecesario la policía de ottawa ha
sido acusada de entregar el capital
canadiense a los manifestantes por lo
que pidieron más ayuda al gobierno sin
dar detalles admitieron errores pero no
es suficiente para los habitantes de la
ciudad tipo en el downtown event si las
personas en el centro están viviendo en
el miedo en el terror se sienten
abandonados por su gobierno federal
erica werner darwish por su gobierno por
la policía deben y responsabilidad por
lo que en realidad es una crisis
nacional la protesta se ha propagado
como un virus a otras ciudades y llegó a
bloquear al estratégico puente
ambassador que conecta a eeuu y canadá
desde protestas en la ciudad de québec e
incluso en alberta donde algunos
campesinos llegaron a caballo el primer
ministro los ha llamado una minoría y
acusa a los conservadores de tener un
doble discurso
women working hemos trabajado con las
autoridades provinciales en todo el país
para implementar las restricciones y las
obligaciones que han salvado vidas
canadienses infortunadamente los
conservadores continúan llamando a
terminar las protestas actuales y
apoyando las allá deben ser líderes más
responsables para superar esto y jugar
menos a las políticas
[Aplausos]
lo ha dicho que no va a llamar al
ejército para dispersar las protestas en
ottawa el 80% de los canadienses están
vacunados según cifras oficiales vamos a
hacer un breve recorrido por nuestro
continente para revisar otras noticias
de las américas esta semana
empezamos en mexico donde el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador propuso
hacer una pausa en las relaciones con
españa de la que se independizó en 1810
y de sus empresas argumentando que no
quiere que les roben a madrid' se
declaró sorprendida al no haber recibido
una nota de rompimiento formal
seguimos en honduras donde el ex
presidente manuel zelaya logró un
acuerdo con los legisladores que se
negaron a apoyar al presidente del
congreso que había respaldado su esposa
la mandataria xiomara castró con la
firma del acuerdo y el reintegro al
partido de los congresistas terminó la
primera crisis política de la primera
presidenta hondureña
y vamos ahora a suramérica a colombia
donde un deslizamiento de tierra en el
centro del país en la zona cafetera
cobró la vida de al menos 15 personas el
alud sepultó varias viviendas en la zona
hubo dos desastres similares en 1926 y
en 1976 por lo que las autoridades son
blanco de críticas por no haber
reubicado a los habitantes
seguimos en bolivia la ex presidenta
interina jan y meañés se declaró en
huelga de hambre al tiempo que inició el
juicio en su contra por su papel en la
crisis política de 2019 que llevó a que
el entonces presidente evo morales
renunciara a su cargo
y terminemos este breve recorrido en
argentina donde sindicatos convocaron a
una manifestación en rechazo al acuerdo
alcanzado entre el presidente alberto
fernández y el fondo monetario
internacional para refinanciar la deuda
adquirida por su predecesor mauricio
macri
y 2022 es un año electoral en eeuu como
es tradición el primer martes de
noviembre se celebrarán las elecciones
de medio término en las que se renueva
un tercio del senado y la totalidad de
la cámara de representantes pero según
encuestas del centro de investigaciones
pew y de la firma ipsos más de la mitad
de los estadounidenses desconfía de la
democracia la creciente polarización
entre demócratas y republicanos ha
reducido la credibilidad de las
instituciones nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez nos cuenta
por qué los ciudadanos no se sienten
representados
mike honesta estratega político
republicano de virginia no votará por su
propio partido en las próximas
elecciones su decepción aumentó al ver
como los simpatizantes de trump se
tomaron el capitolio y además como los
congresistas republicanos han obstruido
la investigación del caso
ellos han tomado un camino peligroso
donde están buscando cualquier forma
para anular y desconocer las elecciones
ellos apoyan personas que promueven
teorías de conspiración y grandes
mentiras para tratar de quedarse con el
poder si es por
frank thomas que siempre ha votado
demócrata también ha perdido interés en
la política y en el partido del
presidente by the end según él los
demócratas no están teniendo en cuenta
sus votantes y el sistema político está
secuestrado por los dos partidos
tradicionales
[Música]
hemos construido un sistema en américa
donde los dos partidos están
prácticamente protegidos por la ley y
entonces el truco se convierte en
hacerse al poder de uno de los dos
partidos el populismo para que lo sepa
era un tercer partido fue el último gran
tercer partido de américa
desde 1852 de boca y republicanos han
ganado todas las elecciones
presidenciales y desde 1856 se han
controlado el congreso bryant base del
ciudadano independiente en washington
nunca ha sentido afinidad con estos dos
partidos porque opinan que ninguno se
preocupa por abordar los problemas que
más afectan a los ciudadanos
no me representan en la mayoría de los
temas y la gente que conozco tampoco se
siente representada y entonces se
convierte en un nosotros contra ellos y
vemos políticos y legisladores que están
forzados a tomar un lado en vez de hacer
lo que es mejor para sus electores y el
país
la democracia está en un punto crucial
repite el presidente joe biden a de
hecho menos del 30 por ciento de los
estadounidenses cree en su sistema
democrático la población quiere ver
cambios reales en vivienda educación y
salud temas que en la disputa
bipartidista han quedado sin resolver
y para el cierre un refrán la basura de
unos desde el tesoro de otros y en
méxico el proyecto cerrando el ciclo le
da un nuevo uso a las botellas de
cerveza y de vino y las convierte en
arte o en joyas no sólo para ayudar al
medio ambiente sino también a aquellos
que no tienen empleo
méxico produce 3 millones de toneladas
de vidrio al año y sólo recicla el 12
por ciento
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción
estuvieron jennifer guevara y luis
fernando montes pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]